okay it's time for audience questions a
little earlier than normal in the week
normally we do these Friday but we are
off Thursday and Friday for the
Thanksgiving holiday here in the United
States so this being the last new show
of the week we're gonna do audience
questions today
Denise wrote in David can you explain
why isn't anybody talking about the
actual July 25 Ukraine phone call that
we don't even know how long it was how
much does the call summary actually
cover apparently it was a 30 minute
phone call and we only got 10 minutes in
the summary yes so this is I've been
repeating this time and again and it's
important Denise that you understand it
but we need more people to understand it
Donald Trump teased the release of the
transcript of the July 25 phone call
when we got that it obviously wasn't a
transcript it was a very partial
transcript transcript we can't even call
it a summary because a summary would in
in sort of a narrative form tell the
story of everything that was said in the
phone call all they did is take a couple
pieces of the transcript the call is
known to have been a half-hour phone
call I think you're being generous when
you say the transcript covers about ten
minutes it might only cover six seven or
eight minutes by my estimation Donald
Trump has continued to say I have
released the transcript and it was a
perfect phone call and the most
disgusting and disturbing thing about
this is if you look at we have a call up
on our YouTube channel from last week's
show it's called something like furious
trumpet implode spectacularly you know
we came up with some interesting title
on YouTube but one of the things that
this person said during their call to me
when they went from one allegation to
another it didn't it was just circular
they eventually said listen we saw the
whole transcript and it's fine and I had
to remind him we didn't see the whole
transcript we saw what are six to eight
minutes of the transcript it was a 30
minute phone call and you have fallen
for the completely fake narrative that
the transcript is out there so are we
ever going to see the full transcript I
don't know if we put more pressure and
and talk about it are we going to see it
I'm not sure we've put more pressure on
seeing Trump's tax returns and I guess
we could say we're slightly closer to
maybe some day
seeing some version of them but it
hasn't really done much so far so you
know there there is scandal fatigue
there are also so many different
elements to this thing there is you've
got the Devin Nunez as a co-conspirator
a traveling to Vienna to meet with
Viktor Shogun on taxpayer dollars you've
got Donald Trump blurting out on Fox and
Friends over the weekend that oh yeah
actually I did ask them to do to look
into this and why should we be giving
them hundreds of millions of dollars
anyway
linking for the first time the quote
investigation and the money my point is
there's so many elements of this that it
can be hard to get refocused on any one
thing even when we've obviously been
lied to and of course we've been lied to
about the transcript we don't have the
transcript we have some paragraphs that
have been pulled from the transcript
even within the paragraphs there are
ellipses which are suspicious the White
House has claimed nothing substantive
has been removed there do we believe it
why would we they lie all the damn time
so I don't know the full scope of what's
in that transcript I remember Trump
thinks the transcript vindicates him it
only is about a third at most of the
call and it's incriminating so just
imagine if they calculated this might
help them or might not damage them just
imagine what the full transcript would
do I'm glad you're thinking about it
Denise I don't know what else we can do
to try to get that full transcript but
all we can do all I can do is to
continue to repeat we've not seen the
full transcript we should see the full
transcript what they released is not a
transcript don't allow Trump to keep
calling it that that's all we can do and
maybe some day even if it's as evidence
in some kind of future proceeding we
maybe will get to see that phone call